[Music]
across the whole food system 20% of
fruits and vegetables that are grown
never make it to human mouth food waste
is a complex problem some of it is
because of the really tight aesthetic
standards of the grocery stores need to
be perfectly round same size the same
color my name is Ben Chester and I'm one
of the co-founders and imperfect foods
[Music]
imperfect foods is a grocery delivery
service that takes produce and groceries
that would normally go to waste and
delivers them to your door for 30% less
in the grocery store we started this
because we noticed there was an
environmental need and there is food
gonna waste a few toys for a country it
would actually be the third largest
emitter of greenhouse gases and then
there's all of the resources all the
water all the labor that goes to waste
we know the more people you reach bigger
impact were able to have in the
environment we wanted to be close to the
farmers and close to the source at over
half of the produce consumed in the US
has grown in California San Francisco
was we came out here with basically a
forklift a warehouse and the shirts on
our backs
the way we work with farms were here to
help them reduce waste so every week
farms basically send us a list of the
fruits and vegetables that they can sell
and we're putting together a complete
menu when you talk to the farmers you
really understand these fruits and
vegetables are kind of their children
and they put so much care and love into
growing them and they have so much pride
in their craft
I love farming because I like the
challenge I like always going up against
mother nature Lakeside organic Gardens
we farm over 3,000 acres we grow over 52
different types of vegetables cilantro
Farsi broccoli cauliflower parsnips
rutabagas turnips lettuces all types
romaine Greenleaf redly iceberg chard we
consider ourselves our one-stop shop for
organic vegetables
we're in our red cabbage field where
it's just been harvested here on my left
I have up a lakeside regular box and to
my right I have the imperfect box
all of them are uniform standard pretty
this just exactly the same same field
same deal just a little bit smaller
ideally for any farmer in this world the
perfect scenario is harvest every piece
of produce that's out in the field
delicious before we we teamed up with
imperfect foods you'd have quite a bit
of product left out in the field now we
have an outlet for those vegetables that
aren't as pretty but they taste just the
same as anything else like they say
don't judge a book by it's cover
same with vegetables you know if they're
a little bit off don't knock it till you
try it
we're here in the imperfect foods
warehouse in San Francisco and so this
is where all the produce the groceries
the meat the dairy everything comes in
from the farms so let's go take a look
at some of the product why would these
mandarins go to a perfect not a grocery
store you can see some of this like
external scarring roughness on the
outside or discoloration but a bit of
peeling the grocery stores really don't
want them and they would normally go to
waste on the farm but a year ago we
expanded beyond produce because we
noticed that there was food go to waste
across the whole food system it's really
well line every box of produce and
groceries we sell helps us fight climate
change and do something good for the
environment
one of the main things that drives us to
be better and to keep pushing is knowing
that our work is helping to leave the
planet in a better place than we found
it for our children now we're headed to
food shift which is one of our community
partners in the Bay Area so sometimes
then we have product that we can't sell
we wanted to still find a home so we
donate to organizations like food shift
we are a combination of food recovery
organization and a social enterprise
kitchen we educate folks who would
otherwise face high barrier to entry for
employment and we hire them for our own
enterprise catering and distribution of
produced meals I want everybody to be
mindful and be kind to each other
and food is a great way to do that
because when we break our proverbial
bread together I think we're closer we
think about our sameness we solve things
together
we put aside our differences so we even
embrace our differences what a privilege
that we get to eat and what a privilege
that we get to cook amazing that food is
really so central to people's identity
and it can really serve as a force to
bring people together and it's also one
of the biggest issues affecting climate
change and health and nutrition and
obesity and so it is really crazy how
this small seed turns a new piece of
fruit or vegetable and then basically
can have so many positive effects on the
world
[Music]